it's been a chaotic two months for
ghana's mobile money merchants after the
introduction of tax on electronic
financial transactions
fear and uncertainty are keeping
customers away
over 4000 agents have lose their job
because myself i was having three
outlets and because of this introduction
two of the outlet is closed
introduced 13 years ago by the country's
telecoms companies mobile money allows
customers to deposit and receive funds
via their phone and use that money for
internet transactions all without
involving the banks or government
until two months ago when a 1.5 tax was
applied to funds
merchants have already started to feel
the pinch
after two years of brisk business
selling clothes online these university
students are closing shop
selling what remains of their stock on
the streets
nowadays people don't really like to do
their online transactions because of the
e-levy
she says it's been weeks since she
received an order
two months after launch government
officials admit that the electronic
transaction levy hasn't generated as
much as expected some reports suggest
that money from the tax isn't up to a
quarter of the projected revenue yet
government is pressing ahead with it
despite public protest
ghana's government defends the tax as
necessary
as the general economy you know
experiences some constraints
aware of the view that being able to
appropriate some resources from that
area will help first of all our fiscal
situation and then the broader ghanaian
economy we should stop looking at africa
experts say the tax is being poorly
implemented you know what i mean by the
design is faulty taxing service it's
it's it's not discriminatory it's you
know it's just
you know all over
when mobile money was introduced in
ghana in 2009 tens of thousands of
people in rural areas got access to
reliable financial services it helped
propel ghana's cashless banking system
but the addition of this new e-tax has
deterred many uses and stifled online
markets and has been one of the main
causes of the recent unrest in the
capital accra ahmed idris al jazeera
koforodoa ghana